Who the hell are you jennifer
walters attorney at law
jen this is your life now whether you like it
or not trouble's gonna find you let's do this
you could be an avenger i'm not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason whether
you like it or not you're now a superhero
very good i'm just trying to
show you no i'm done i'm shown
i did not go to law school to become a vigilante
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice all right let's do this
that name better not stick chris i'm not gonna be
a superhero what else you're
gonna do as a hulk lawyer
we just started a superhuman law division
and i want the she-hulk to be the face-off
we do things by the book the book of his
chanting the book of american uh loss
Welcome back everyone marvel just released
a new she-hulk trailer we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of new daredevil and we got
new details on what's going on with the new hulk
movie that we just found out about thanks to
some very sharp eyed fans pouring over a bunch
of legal documents between disney and all the
hulk solo movies so i'll explain what's going on
because it ties what's happening in later marvel
phase 5 with captain america 4 new world order
in the thunderbolts movie if you're brand new
to the channel i will be doing videos for all
the she-hulk episodes they start next week be
sure to subscribe to get all those we're doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let
me know what you want them to do for the plot of
the next hulk solo movie in the mcu yes there's
a ton of new daredevil and all these she-hulk
trailers i'll talk about that in a second after
i talk about the hulk movie i feel like everyone's
really just wondering what the deal is with marvel
making the next hulk solo movie and to make
another daredevil and she-hulk joke thanks to some
very good lawyers fans have found some interesting
information in all the legal documents at marvel
so the big green elephant in the room right now
is marvel's been sitting on a new hulk solo movie
why haven't they released any since the incredible
hulk film originally the incredible hulk with
edward norton was planned is a trilogy of hulk
movies you probably heard about this before
the sequel would have come out a couple years
later kind of the same timing of iron man and
iron man 2 iron man 3 the same thing with the thor
movies same thing with the captain america movies
like a couple years between them tim blake nelson
revealed that his leader character would have been
one of the main villains of the incredible hulk
sequel movie and the third movie probably would
have gotten into some red hulk thunderbolt raw
stuff the main reason marvel hasn't released
a hulk solo movie since the incredible hulk is
because universal has held the distribution rights
to all the marvel movies where hulk was the main
character or they used hulk in the title of the
movie the same is true for characters like neymar
like they held a couple of characters rights like
that like that's why you haven't seen a name
or solo movie marvel's work around to that was
to have hulk be a backup character in all the
avengers movies like they gave him an r kind
of spread across all the avengers films and now
namor for instance is in black panther wakanda
forever is one of the villains but technically
he's not a villain he's kind of like an anti-hero
they're big characters metaphorically and
literally like namor is one of the biggest
characters in black panther wakanda forever
but they're not in the titles of the movies
universal's rights to those characters made it so
that if marvel wanted to release a hulk solo movie
for instance they'd be forced to let universal
distribute the movie earning a ton of the box
office earnings and disney and marvel didn't want
that like they wanted all the money for themselves
obviously but universal's contract with them gave
them the rights to release all hulk movies until
and here's where we get the really good lawyers
in the mcu for the win until the year 2023 they
had a contract that expired after about 15 years
from the release of the most recent hulk movie
which was the incredible hulk releasing in june
2008 so technically marvel can now release the
next hulk solo movie in july 2023 now if you
look at the marvel phase 5 schedule the marvel
phase 6 schedule we got at comic con july 2023
is literally next year it's not that far away
and of course their schedule for marvel phase 5 is
already booked solid between movies and tv series
they're releasing loki season 2 in
the marvels movie around that time
the only open dates they have right now on
the schedule are later in marvel phase six
after the thunderbolts movie in the fantastic
four movie so that's like the earliest that the
new hulk solo movie could come out but you see why
marvel's doubling down now on introducing so many
new hook characters like she-hulk it's also pretty
likely they'll eventually do a she-hulk season 2
because there's so many opportunities for bringing
new characters in through that mark ruffalo also
said on the side a couple years ago that he'd
been pitching new hulk movies and stories to
kevin feige and they were trying to get something
going in the background it was just a matter of
when the timing would be right like when would we
actually be able to release a new hulk solo movie
and it sounds like in 2023 they could actually
start making plans for a later release date like
marvel phase six marvel phase seven it's basically
the same situation that happened with daredevil
himself coming back into the mcu along with the
other marvel netflix characters marvel had to
wait a couple years for the rights to expire after
netflix canceled all those marvel netflix shows
marvel couldn't just turn right around immediately
the minute after they got cancelled and bring them
all back in movies and tv shows like it took a
couple years for that to expire as for the actual
plot of this new hulk movie that's the reason
you keep hearing all those world war hulk rumors
like a lot of people have heard that the plot
would be a slightly different version of a
world war hulk film with hulk versus pretty much
everybody in the mcu like hulk versus both the
avengers and the thunderbolts like all the heroes
and all the villains and if we're talking about a
couple years out now like 2025 2026 2027 at this
point by that point they'll also have the new
versions of the x-men and mutants in the mcu like
we've just started to see them tease that like in
the miss marvel series a lot of people saw recent
contracts and some more legal documents saying
that there were some rights issues with doing new
x-men mutant characters inside the mcu until the
year 2025 and that's one of the reasons why they
waited so long to do new x-men solo film so in
the wilderness they just have to wait a couple
years for the contract to expire on doing new
hulk solo movies is kind of a similar situation
with doing new versions of the x-men characters
but all those weird legal rights issues will be
cleared up by the times that they actually have
open release dates for movies so it's not that
big of a deal and i talked about all the planet
hulk easter eggs world war hulk easter eggs in
the last she-hulk trailer with the sakara ship
they actually started setting up weapon x way back
in the incredible hulk film really good example is
thunderbolt ross kept talking about the weapons
plus program with abomination like he basically
took the super soldier serum program evolved it
into weapons plus pulled it out of mothballs as
he says weapons plus in the comics is the program
that births weapon x eventually like deadpool for
example is one of the weapons plus people think of
weapon x when they think of wolverine but weapon x
is actually weapon 10 like he's the 10th iteration
of the weapons plus program a lot of you comic
book fans will remember that wolverine debuted in
the incredible hulk comics so by the time they're
ready to do like a new version of an mcu wolverine
they could actually do a legit wolverine versus
hulk story inside a hulk solo movie but let me
know in the comments if they can release a new
hulk movie in a couple more years what do you want
them to actually do for the plot of that movie
talking about all the new she-hulk and the
daredevil footage we see way more matt murdock and
him in the yellow daredevil suit from the comics a
lot of people asking why is it yellow well yellow
was the original costume when he initially debuted
in the comics but in the mcu i'm sure they'll have
a funny way of explaining like why would a blind
person want to wear a very bright colored yellow
and red costume like that the colors kind of clash
a little bit the way the she-hulk writers talked
about it they said that they had a lot of witty
banter between matt murdock and jennifer walters
just because of the way the matt murdock character
is he has this really quick wit he tells a lot of
jokes but he has a very particular style of
dialogue it sounds like they have a lot of
daytime scenes with them as matt murdock lawyer
and jennifer walters lawyer going at each other
in court like that's the whole reason why you
would have daredevil in a she-hulk series because
she's trying to become a superhero and still be
a lawyer and that's basically who daredevil is
like he's matt murdock lawyer by day in daredevil
by night so they keep teasing that she's part of
this new superhero law division at her law firm
she probably has to defend someone who's on the
opposite side of a case that matt murdock is also
representing so it's like them going at each other
in court by day and then they meet each other
at night as vigilantes really good example this
is when daredevil is telling all kinds of jokes
the first time he meets karen page with foggy
nelson here how long have you been practicing
law sometimes it's 12 22 a.m about seven hours
well if you go from where we passed the ball
what's going from i got our own desks oh then yeah
seven hours you have to picture daredevil being
a little bit like this telling jokes and going
back and forth with jennifer walters like kind
of playful but also very sharp the big reminder
she-hulk episode 1 is gonna release next week
they're on thursdays now my videos will post on
thursdays be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those videos and if you have
any special requests for hulk bonus videos or for
my she-hulk episode videos just write them in the
comments below there were a couple of the really
big announcements about upcoming marvel projects
and new trailers so i'll try to post those as
quickly as possible we also found out about a
whole bunch of spider-man characters that they're
doing in the next big spider-man madam web movie
everyone click here for that new she-hulk world
war hulk trailer video in easter eggs and click
here for my new flash movie trailer and learn
what's going on with the future of the dc movies
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!